good morning everyone in anticipation of
seeing a proposal finally
uh from the other side of the aisle on
the other side of pennsylvania avenue
i invited the distinguished leader and
the democratic leader in the senate to
join us today
to have some observation about what we
have seen
we thought we would have in hand we'll
see
we come together today on a day that
marks
where for the 18th straight week
the 18th straight week more than one
million people
have filed for unemployment claims
we come at a time when today we will
reach
they predict that we will reach four
million
cases in our country what's important
about that
is the steam roller that it is the
the uh acceleration that this has
it doesn't diminish because people have
filed for unemployment insurance so we
must have reached the peak
it continues this is the trump virus
acceleration of all of this now listen
to this
it took just about 100 days
to reach 1 million people infected
it took 43 days to talk to get to 2
million
it took 27 days to get to 3 million
and it took 16 days to get to 4
million that acceleration
there's an assault on the lives and the
livelihood
of the american people if we want to
open our schools
if we have to open our economy we must
defeat this virus
we had hoped with this legislation the
heroes act
we put forth ours two months and one
week ago
they said they needed a pause well
they still are not prepared you can use
the pause to prepare
and what we have seen so far falls very
short
of the challenge that we face in order
to defeat the virus
and to open to in order to open our
schools
and to open our economy science science
science and science seems to be
ignored the delay the denial
have caused deaths we can do something
about it
but we can't we must have uh
the appropriate response to it in terms
of
testing tracing treating
just dealing with the virus and not
ignoring
and saying well too many tests and i
don't believe in tests and all the rest
of that
so we have a real challenge for getting
politics for getting partisanship
this is patriotism for our country
we're up to four million people in a
matter of just
over two weeks from the three million
mark
we have to act and and what they're
proposing
falls far short but that don't yield to
distinguish
uh rank leader in the in the senate
uh who has been well he'll describe to
you what he has been up to
but i salute him and the senate
democrats for the work that they have
done
to make sure that the first four coveted
bills were all
bipartisan hopefully this bill will be
too
mr leader thank you speaker pelosi and
thank you for all the great work you
have done on
so many things and now most notably the
heroes bill which are senate democratic
caucus is in full support of now faced
with the greatest economic challenge in
75 years
the greatest public health challenge in
a century
democrats have waited for months for our
senate colleagues
to get our senate republican colleagues
to get serious
about helping the american people who
have suffered so much during this
pandemic
now that senate republicans have finally
woken up to the calamity in our country
they have been so divided so
disorganized so unprepared
that they have struggled to even draft a
partisan proposal within their own
conference
they can't come together even after all
this time
it appears the republican legislative
response to covid
is unified unserious
unsatisfactory the republican disarray
in dithering has serious potentially
deadly consequences
for tens of millions of americans 1.4
million americans implied applied for
unemployment last week
the first time the number rose since
march tomorrow the moratorium on
evictions expires
exposing millions of americans to the
risk
of being kicked out of their homes
through no fault of their own
and over the weekend many states will
send out their final enhanced
unemployment checks
but here we are still waiting for the
republicans
to put together a partisan bill that
will never become
law just so they can muster up the
courage
to negotiate and now we're hearing that
the republicans may able to may only be
able to produce a series of disjointed
small proposals
that don't even add up to a coherent
plan to fight covet
from what we've read in public reports
their proposals or serious
series of proposals won't include food
assistance for hungry kids
from what we know it won't include
rental assistance or extend the
moratorium on evictions
keeping tens of a million tens of
millions of americans with a roof over
their heads
it won't provide hazard pay to essential
workers who've been risking their lives
and their families lives
since the crisis began it won't make the
necessary investments in communities of
color
that have been ravaged by this virus
disproportionately so
it won't provide new funding for state
and local governments
and the need to keep teachers and bus
drivers and sanitation workers on the
job
and from what we know it won't even
include funding
to ensure our elections are safe this
fall
remarkably the likely centerpiece of the
republican legislative response to covet
is not help for the 20 to 30 million
unemployed americans or resources for
testing and tracing
the centerpiece of the republican
proposal is a liability shield
to protect big corporations from
lawsuits if they put their workers at
risk
seriously leader mcconnell has made
corporate immunity
the centerpiece of the republican
response
once again the republican senate is far
more comfortable providing relief to big
corporations
than relief to workers and families
how about instead of shielding
corporations from liability
we shield renters from eviction how
about instead of shielding corporations
from liability
we shield the unemployed from poverty
according to reports the white house and
senate republicans want to cut the
enhanced unemployment benefits that
democrats secured
in the cares act to a percentage
of a worker's former wage that's right
america
if you lost your job through no fault of
your own and can't go back to work
because this administration has
mismanaged the crisis
republicans want you to take a pay cut
of 30 percent or even more
the number of unemployment claims
unfortunately increased this week for
the first time in 15 weeks
and republicans are fighting with
themselves over how much to cut
unemployment benefits they're totally
disorganized
they're disconnected from the reality
americans are confronting
every day republicans fight among
themselves
over how low to go and hardworking
americans continue to suffer
democrats are ready to work republicans
need to pull their head out of the sand
get their act together sit down with
speaker pelosi and me
and start negotiating a real package
thank you mr leader you spelled it out
perfectly and when i'm listening to you
i'm thinking
what is it that the trump administration
and the republicans in congress
have against working families in our
country
as they sit around their table and join
their corporate friends at the corporate
board table
we have to be thinking about what's
going on at the kitchen table of
america's families
many more people than ever many people
who never thought they would
are going to food banks and yet this
legislation that they're proffering
has nothing to address food insecurity
in our country and it's about our
children to to
millions and millions of children are
food insecure
yet nothing there for that and as the
leader said in terms of rent people will
be in the streets the evictions will
continue and yet in our bill
we have a proposal who does which does
just that modeled after some
past initiatives for emergency security
so in the heroes act we have as you know
honor our heroes which as leader says
their bill does not
health care workers transit workers are
first responders
food suppliers sanitation workers and
the rest
nicks they say no to that
in terms of what we have to do to
address the virus
they are scientifically
in absentia they just don't get it they
don't believe in science they don't
believe in governance
so why should they pay attention to
science and do something
in governance about it so they make a
token thing and now they're saying well
we're going to use some of the money we
did before
which they didn't spend before so this
is a a crisis
this is a crisis for our country i had
hoped
that we as as we do in legislating when
they offered their bills before
they offered their uh first version of
the cares act
we countered when they offered their the
next version of the
ppp we countered we offered this
legislation
we thought they would counter with
something that was at least reconcilable
but this doesn't reconcile with the
needs of the american people
it is another example of their
dereliction and duty
for not facing the reality of what this
virus is doing to our the help the lives
the livelihood and actually the life of
our democracy with that we're pleased to
take any questions
yes ma'am madam speaker it seems as
though these negotiations are as you've
outlined
hitting some speed bumps and millions of
americans
are facing their unemployment benefits
running out
at the end of next week if you can't get
a bigger deal
are you open to temporarily extending
those benefits
this is a package we cannot
piecemeal this uh this is as you see it
has an integrity
it has a oneness about meeting the needs
of the american people
defeating the virus as we honor our
heroes and put money into the pockets of
the american people
but depending on what they come up with
what do you think the only thing i'd say
in answer to your question
we're not going to lee take care of one
portion
of suffering people and leave everyone
else hanging that's what they may want
to do
take care of this and then they'll go
home no way this is a comprehensive
proposal
that addresses the many problems of
covid and we have to address it as a
totality
you think we can do it by the end of
next week look
leader mcconnell didn't even show up and
make a speech this morning
i had it all to myself rare moment um
but in any case uh i hope so but they're
so divided
they're so divided and there's no
leadership from the president at the
same time that they know the president
has no leadership they're afraid to buck
him on
anything and he doesn't know how to
solve this problem as we have seen
so much of what has happened so much of
the illness
and so much of the deaths and so much of
the uh
economic uh hardship and health hardship
is because this administration has a no
direction no plan
no straight line of attack
and what we have in the heroes act was a
gift to them
as a strategic plan for testing
tracing treating isolation of course
mask wearing sanitation so the other day
when the president
embraced mask what he was doing was
admitting
admitting how wrong he was for months
and in that period of time
many more people died and even since
we did the uh the heroes at two months
and one week ago
2.5 million more americans have become
infected and 55 million
more people have died while they were
pausing saying we did some of them
saying we don't need
anything more and one more point in
reference to your question
one of the reasons we're up against this
cliff is because the republicans have
dithered
the heroes act passed two months and a
week ago
nancy and i sent a letter to mcconnell
three weeks ago saying let's sit down
and negotiate nothing
now we're up against the cliff we got to
solve the whole thing because there are
a lot of different
two parts cliffs this so have you been
actually given a piece of paper or a
phone call from the white house in the
politics this is what our plan is
nothing like that okay and number two
what we learned some of this early this
morning was what we learned from k
street
that's where they kind of and then the
second part is then
uh you stood here two weeks ago and said
three trillion you talked about the
three divisions of the trillion here
they keep talking about wanting to stick
to about a trillion dollars
but where is the where is the give there
if you get anything short of three
trillion
if it's one and a half billion if you're
two trillion dollars we're going to
negotiate the amount of money here in
this room now
but let's let's see what what what was
really important to see their proposal
and that's what
the leader kept asking for put it on
paper we need a specific
proposal a bill we've put in a bill
legislative language that passed the
house
you can't just say five lines and let's
sit down and negotiate the devil is all
in the details and
we don't know what's in and what's out
we don't know if the president's on
board
you know is this going to be mcconnell's
proposal is this going to be the senate
republicans proposal
is this going to be mcconnell and the
trump's proposal no one even knows any
of that
you can't negotiate that way and
actually what
leader mcconnell had been saying is uh
the impression he gave was that he was
going to be negotiating
with the senate democrats and then they
would come up with something
as in as congress works its will one
side makes a proffer the other the other
body
uh then comes back with what they have
but
to your point they have nothing for
state and local
in our bill that's 915 billion dollars
state local tribal governments
and territories 915 billion
go to speaker.gov heroes act and see
what it means to you
in your community and then understand
it's half of what they were
willing to add to the national debt for
their tax cut for the rich
83 percent of the benefits going to the
top one percent but
but so when you see what they have on
paper
you see what they don't have on paper so
when they say a billion
a trillion dollars and nothing for state
and local
nothing for uh food stamps feeding the
hungry nothing for helping with
uh rent and the rest of that nothing
so many things they don't have then you
realize how they're at a trillion
dollars
how unacceptable it is yes sir
uh madam speaker you were pretty clear
last week that on the unemployment
benefit that 600 is is the number that
you were going to be sticking with
has that changed at all in the week now
that you've seen at least some
numbers floated from the other side you
want to speak to that i mean i'm all for
the six hundred dollars because people
really need it
and but again as i said to you then
uh we have issues that relate to direct
payments for people and the size of what
that is
and the rest uh but i go to the table
with the with the um uh commitment to
the 600 dollars mr leader
our unemployment provision has kept
millions out of poverty
millions it really has i mean they like
to talk about the six hundred dollars
i like to talk about the 83 percent of
two trillion dollars that they gave to
the richest people
the top one percent in our country why
are they worried about
whether it's 600 or 400 or 500
people really need that and as we try to
bolster
look we all know that there's a floor
for the stock market that the fed
everything that is being done is to keep
the stock market from going
down past a point why can't we have a
floor
for america's working families and while
they bolster the stock market which is
not a bad thing i'm not criticizing i'm
just saying it's a fact why do they have
to make a fuss
over 600 which means a lot to many
working families
in our countries especially single moms
in certain parts of the country where
the unemployment benefit
is very low uh again we can try to help
businesses as we try with ppp and the
rest of that
and we can help them pay the rent and we
help them pay their employees and we can
help them pay the utility bill
but if ain't got no customers they still
have a problem
and this money is really important for
people to spend eject
inject demand into the economy create
jobs yes ma'am
thank you madam speaker the republican
proposal is about 70
of approximately 70 percent of the uh
wage replacement
and we don't know that yeah we can you
can't negotiate with a
climber marriage a c-h-i n-e-r-a
we don't know what it is we do different
things all the time from different
people
would you agree that it shouldn't exceed
prior wages i mean do you have anything
like the proposal we have it's kept
millions of people out of poverty
it's in the it's in the uh heroes bill
to be extended till january 31st
and let me just say that there's a a
great deal that
is being said by the republicans that is
not true
uh i always you've heard me say many
times they'll have an anecdote about
somebody who didn't go to work because
they got 600. the plural anecdote is not
data that's our fundamental principle
and appropriations committee
we need data okay so we do know
that millions of families in our country
depend on that 600 oh they're not going
to go to work
oh we want here's what they'll say we
want them to go to work they're
essential workers
we're not going to give them any osha
protections and if they don't go to work
and take that risk to their lives and
that of their families
if they don't go to work they can't get
unemployment insurance
so they're there to sabotage working
families that's why i say
what did working families ever do to the
republicans and the president that
they're out to get them
a b they'll say as they're saying well
we're not giving money to state and
local because some of their
their governments are mismanaged we're
not talking about that
we're talking about the receipts that
they have
for paying for a corona virus
a and the revenue lost because of the
corona virus
all over the country democratic and
republican nonpartisan whatever you want
to call it red blue purple
whatever so they're using an excuse that
has nothing to do with a corona virus
so they're they're
engaged in distortions delay
denial disorder distortions
very damaging to our economy very deadly
to our people
let me just take another person that
because that's how we do it here yes
thank you madam speaker
on another subject we would do with the
leader here to comment on
federal agents out in the streets in
portland and possibly chicago
jeff merkley is on the floor now with
legislation that i support and others
that fundamentally says the police
officers any federal officers have to
have id
where they're from and what their name
is and more importantly
if they go off federal property itself
and patrol streets or anything else they
have to get the permission of the
executive in charge the mayor or
governor
that's how this should be done president
trump always likes diversions
he's miserably failing at testing he's
miserably failing at contact tracing
he's miserably failing at getting the
economy going he's miserably failing
on the greatest crisis america has in
the american people note
so he tries a diversion there's a real
answer the answer is merkley's bill
and that's the bill that is supported by
the house democrats as well i hope the
republicans will join us
it's very very important the use of
stormtroopers
under the guise of law and order is a
tactic
that is not uh appropriate to our
country
in any way so on american what has
happened it is so
in keeping with third world countries
and dictatorships you haul somebody
off the streets don't tell them who you
are why you're doing it etcetera it's
also unconstitutional
yes ma'am alexandria acosta cortez she
went down to the floor today and put in
the congressional record what
congressman yoho
said to her and she said that you know
having a wife having a daughter
doesn't make a decent man what's your
response to what she did and
do you think congressman yoho's apology
was enough
well to tell you the honest truth we're
focused on trying to save lives
uh with the uh uh with our bill to um
uh prevent to to kill this virus just to
destroy this
virus and we're there to open up our
economy and our schools
the fact that the behavior of one of the
members is such that the whole women's
caucus
the democratic women's caucus has gone
to the floor at a time when our
floor time is very precious tells you
how
important this is and it's it's
an uh a manifestation of
attitudes in our society really i can
tell you that firsthand
they've called me names for at least at
least
20 years of leadership 18 years of
leadership
i don't know you know what's so funny is
you'd say to them do you not have a
daughter
you don't have a mother do you not have
a sister do you not have a wife
what makes you think that you can be
so and this is the word i use for them
condescending
in addition to being disrespectful i i i
one of my i don't say favorites but one
of the most
is when we were discussing women's
reproductive health a number of years
ago on the floor of the house
they were so angry with me because i had
five children in six years to the day so
i had
standing on the issue and they got up
there and said on the floor of the house
nancy pelosi thinks she knows more about
having babies than the pope
yes so there's no
no limit to the the disrespect
or the lack of acknowledgement of
the strength of women and nothing
brings more nothing is more wholesome
for our government for our politics for
our country than the increased
participation of women
and women will be treated with respect
thank you thank you all
opening day yes how bad are you
[Music]
what do i think of the giants kneeling
i'm so proud of gabe kapler our new
general manager who knelt with him